vegan burgers are a sensible thing to
find on a supermarket shelf but vegan
Tomatoes wouldn't be in fact those
tomatoes would sound a bit suspicious
it's the same as the old joke about
asbestos free cereal those labels are
ignoring one of Grice's Maxim's a set of
guidelines that explain how we
communicate with each other Paul Grice
was a philosopher of language in 75 he
published a paper called logic and
conversation he was dealing with the
gaps between natural language and what's
called logical formalism basically we
communicate far more than just the
literal meaning of our words
Grice wrote that for that to be possible
without having some hyper logical
unambiguous language we must be
operating under some shared assumptions
what he called the co-operative
principle we assume that we are
cooperating with each other when we're
talking which is obvious right but
there's a deeper point there we all try
to fit what other people say into the
context of what's happening or what's
already been said that's part of why
when we play a computer game and a
character says exactly the same thing no
matter if we've just saved their village
or burned down the house we can tell
that they're pre-programmed we can't
find a way to fit their words to the
situation so here are Grice's Maxim's
and if you're not in a video game these
are the rules that we assume our
conversation partners are following
although despite how they're written
they are not prescriptive you must do
this rules they are just guidelines
so first the maxim of quantity give as
much information as required and no more
which is what we're talking about with
vegan Tomatoes we already know they're
vegan from the word tomato giving too
much information is strange
next the maxim of quality tell the truth
next there's the maxim of relation the
irrelevant to the person you're talking
to will assume that what you're saying
is related to what they just said in
some way and they'll try to find what
that connection is and finally the maxim
of manner be clear in what you're saying
although Grice phrase that in a way that
I don't think actually follows his own
guidelines actually all those Maxim's
were stated and restated at length but
then he was a philosopher
they tend to do that so let's have a
good example of using Grice's Maxim's
and after that a deliberately bad walk
let's imagine someone says I'm out of
petrol and in reply I say others have
damage down the road without context
just using the super little logical
meaning of those sentences there's no
connection there those are just two
factual statements but if you assume
that I'm trying to follow the
co-operative principle then you can
automatically work out a lot more using
the maxim of relation the garage
probably has petrol using the maxim of
quantity we know that that's all I need
to say in order to imply hey you can
push your car there you can buy fuel and
you can solve your whole being stranded
problem a problem which by the way was
also completely implied using the
co-operative principle and doing the
graphics in now but until this moment
all that back story about a stranded car
was implied just by the words I'm out of
petrol now using the maxim of quality we
can assume that I'm telling the truth
and this isn't a lie or a guess and
using the maxim of manner even someone
who is confused by my dialect can work
out that garage probably means the
British slang for what Americans would
call a gas station it's not just
someone's garage home where they parked
their car that that would be weird all
that doesn't apply from just the phrase
there's a garage down the road but what
about when we don't follow the Maxim's
Grice says but in that case we're asking
for conversational implicature which is
to say that we are implying something
not said there are two ways to break a
maxim you can violate it or you can
flout it
violating it is just like flying it's
breaking Maxim to deceive but flouting
is breaking a maxim in a way that you
expect the other person to pick up on
one of gryce's examples is a philosophy
professor who has to write a grad school
letter of recommendation for a student
that they have no faith in and yes I
absolutely believe that this is just
Christ
quietly grumbling about one of his
students anyway the professor writes the
letter using the co-operative principle
the students command of English is
excellent and his attendance at
tutorials has been regular
that is technically a letter of
recommendation but it doesn't follow the
maxim of quantity it is far too little
information it doesn't say the students
actually could it philosophy
it's flouting the maximum when someone
does that they are hoping that the
person reading or listening will
understand what they're really trying to
communicate and that's why you see
product packaging that says vegan tomato
or asbestos free cereal or more
realistically low in fact or low in
sugar they're flouting Grice's Maxim's
to imply that the other brands aren't or
to imply those claims are good things to
be and that might not be true but it's
not technically lying it's just not
playing fair by the co-operative
principle into that or that really is
some sort of evil animal by-product
tomato out there
thanks to my co-authors maliwal and
Gretchen McCulloch Gretchen's podcast
link fusee azzam is linked in the
description it is well worthless
you